there had been quite a buzz at the SCP
Foundation when only a few days ago word
had spread of a possibly anomalous
archaeological Day excavations At A
redacted location in the Middle East had
on Earth what appeared to be an ancient
Shrine with a large Stone tablet as its
centerpiece inscribed with ruins of a
language lost to the ages now normally
this wouldn't be nearly enough to
attract the interest of the foundation
especially without an overtly anomalous
component to the shrine usually this
would pass unnoticed as just a slightly
interesting discovery that could perhaps
make its way to a museum but along with
the tablet were a pair of carvings on
the surface of the stone Shrine these
depicted a pair of figures seemingly
Rivals that were locked together in an
endless cycle of conflict and that was
what caught the collective eye of the
foundation the figures in these carvings
seemed to Bear a very close almost candy
resemblance to scp-073 and
scp-076 better known respectively as
Kane and Abel while the carvings were
too large to be transported in their
entirety the stone tablet bearing its
inscription was requisitioned by the SCP
Foundation and almost immediately after
it arrived the buzz surrounding it died
down Focus shifting to one of what was
considered the far Bolder and more
exciting anomalies but one researcher by
the name of Isaac Graves remains solely
focused on the mysterious tablet
researcher Graves was determined to be
the one who discovered the connection
between this Stone and both
scp-073 and
scp-076 many had long suspected that
this pair of anomalous Immortals were
related Brothers even perhaps this
tablet and the shrine it was found in
held the key to proving once and for all
if that long-standing theory was indeed
true of course the biggest obstacle
standing in graves's way was nobody knew
how to read what had been inscribed on
the tablet the language was runic and so
many thousands of years old that there
was no way of translating it or at least
no quick way understanding what was
written on the stone was going to take
some time several years of tireless
research passed with everyday researcher
Graves spent studying the tablet feeling
like a step closer to revealing its
Secrets he had to become fluent in all
the languages spoken in the region where
the shrine was first discovered along
with all the variations and dialects of
each then it was a case of working
backwards finding the ancient roots of
each of these modern patterns of speech
and writing and eventually after at last
discovering the right linguistic Branch
going through the inscription word by
word to translate it it was only when he
stepped back and read the tablet in its
entirety that Graves understood what he
was truly looking at realization dawned
on him the researcher turned and
barreled through the facility corridors
he demanded to speak urgently with the
site director the senior research staff
and anyone and everyone in Authority who
would listen and all because what
researcher Graves had found could render
all prior study of two prolific
anomalies completely null and void he
believed that the tablet described the
true tragic origin of both Cain and Abel
as Graves gathered his various superiors
he recounted what he had learned from
the tablet years and years ago many
Millennia before the dawn of modern
civilization there had lived an isolated
family they lived in a small rural
Homestead maintained a decent amount of
farmland and traded crops and livestock
with Traders from a nearby Township in
order to survive two sons were
eventually born to a mother and father
whose names were forgotten to the annals
of history but their sons names had
however would not only live on in Legend
but would one day refer to a pair of
anomalous individuals of course as most
of the foundation higher-ups in the room
quickly guessed the two brothers were
named Kane and Abel now according to the
legend researcher Graves had translated
from the tablet Kane was the family's
firstborn son and for a Time the pride
and joy of his mother and father as he
got older and reached an age where he
was able to Kane began to help his
father tend to the Farmland around their
home until one day Kane's mother fell
pregnant again with yet another son
however the birth of this new child was
fraught with far more difficulty and
sadly claimed the life of the boy's
mother as his father held his newborn
younger brother in his arms Kane stood
by his mother's side as she passed away
his father named the new child Abel and
raised him the best as he could however
the loss of his wife had stricken him
with grief which took a toll on him as
the years rolled on and able grew up it
seemed with every passing day as the
young boy grew into a man time had the
opposite effect on his father he became
frail unable to farm any longer causing
Kane to take up maintaining the crops in
his father's increasing absence until
one day the father of the two boys fell
ill eventually succumbing to sickness he
too died reunited with his wife but
leaving the pair of brothers alone with
only each other the final bit of wisdom
their father had imparted to Cain and
Abel was to trust in the old man on the
hill sure enough a figure would often
appear looking down at the valley where
they lived according to their father
this man was the creator the one who had
made the world around them all the
heavens and every part of the universe's
Majesty he could control life and death
every force of nature only existed and
behaved in accordance with the Creator's
design and before his eventual passing
Cain and Abel's father had told his two
sons that if they made a small sacrifice
to the Creator then he would provide for
them and watch over the brothers and so
following their father's wishes Kane and
Abel would regularly make their Journey
up the nearby Hill to where the old man
resided sometimes he would speak with
them friendly conversing while the two
men made certain to be as polite as they
knew how to be they would present the
Creator with coats sheep and all manner
of livestock that they kept on their
Farm their offering to him in exchange
for plentiful harvests and the safe
passage of their mother and father into
the great beyond the Creator would tell
either Kane or Abel to kill their
offering alternating between each of the
brothers every time according to the
stone tablet back then this was in a
time before man had learned how to kill
another man not a single person had ever
murdered another but that was soon to
change as the brothers grew up Abel
reaching his 20s and Kane just slightly
older than that they can't continue to
work on their Homestead Kane was still
tending to his parents land farming
crops to feed them both and sell at
Market it was a hard laborious life the
heat of an unforgiving Sun bearing down
on him in the fields Cain loathed it
every day was exhausting but he knew if
he stopped then he and his brother would
perish Abel meanwhile saw to the animals
becoming a Shepherd in contrast to
Cain's attitude towards farming able
seemed to rather enjoy his work herding
the cattle he had a good command over
them they listened to what he said and
that seemed at least a cane to make his
younger brother's job unfairly easier
there was some disparity between Cain
and Abel the tablet did not state what
had started it maybe it was simply the
fact they stuck so unmovably to their
roles rather than alternating or perhaps
it was a lingering resentment on Kane's
part after all their mother had died
giving birth to Abel which could have so
easily led to the older brother laying
the blame aim at his sibling's feet even
more so as losing his wife had been the
thing that started their father's
eventual decline causing him to die too
but all was as the Creator wielded Kane
told himself although it did little to
ease the pain of his parents deaths and
did little to stop what would happen
next having grown jealous of his younger
brother watching him enjoy his work
hurting the animals and getting to rest
for most of the day while he slaved away
Kane decided to bring his own sacrifice
to the Creator while Abel ready the goat
to be offered much like they had done
numerous times before Kane gathered up
the best of his crops for the season and
the pair made their Journey up the hill
presenting the elderly man with both
their offerings he seemed confused as to
why there was more this time it may have
been that the Creator interpret this as
greed on the brother's part bringing him
a greater offering in exchange for
greater reward or possibly just out of
preference for the type of sacrifice he
accepted but whatever the reason the
Creator seem to favor Abel's offering of
the goat over the crops Cain had
presented the long walk back down into
the valley was tense both brothers were
silent but it was clear to Abel that
something was wrong with Cain he was
seething practically shaking with anger
although the younger of the two brothers
could never have predicted what his
sibling would do next or that he'd never
make it to the bottom of the hill in a
blind fit of rage Kane lunged at his
brother attacking him out of spite at
the fact that his sacrifice had been
favored in his hands Abel still held the
blade used to sacrifice his livestock to
the Creator until Kane struck him the
knife clattered to the ground only for
The Elder of the two brothers to reach
for it completely overwrought with his
anger all Kane could do was to undo Abel
as they had done to the other sacrifices
maybe then the Creator would favor him
instead of his younger sibling the wise
old man was initially horrified to see
Kane returning so soon carrying the body
of table over his shoulders which he
then dumped at the Creator's feet no one
on earth had ever killed a fellow human
being before this was completely
unexpected it was only when he saw the
Saturn look in the old man's eyes and
his brother's corpse lying still on the
ground that the true gravity of what
he'd done hit Cain he pleaded with the
Creator to reverse what he'd done saying
over and over again that he had made a
mistake the old man agreed to oblige
perhaps knowing or just believing that
Kane hadn't wanted to kill Abel
controlling the forces of life and death
itself he resurrected the younger of the
brothers and in the process turned him
into a mighty warrior with an
inexhaustible supply of Weaponry so that
he would never be slain again and could
always defend himself from harm however
the same rage that I'd possessed Kane
now took hold of Abel with his Newfound
power he immediately went to exact a
terrible brutal Vengeance on his brother
witnessing the ferocity of the younger
man and the horrible wounds able
inflicted on Cain the Creator was forced
to intervene as he had done before he
returned Cain to life and repaired the
damage to his body but he sought fit to
punish both the brothers for what they
had done out of jealousy anger and
revenge the old man deemed it so that
neither one of them could die Abel would
fall but Return To Life each time
meanwhile the Creator condemned Kane to
wander the Earth forever but the man who
had once farmed and made the land
fertile for crops would never again get
to witness the Majesty of nature
wherever he went the plants around Cain
would wither and die while any wound
that was inflicted upon him would be
reflected back onto the one who caused
it as a constant reminder of the harm he
had done to his little brother Abel and
thus started all of this after telling
the legend in its entirety researcher
Graves led the site director and Senior
researchers back to his lab where he had
been studying the stone tablet they
arrived just in time to see it come
gambling into dust destroying all the
records of what Graves had learned about
scp-073 and
scp-076 the tragic story of how Kane and
Abel came to be was lost forever want to
own an SCP of your own go to scpswag.com
for premium anomalous merchandise now go
check out
scp-073-kane and scp-076 able for more
of these ill-fated Immortal Brothers